are you ready for
Taylor Swift earns 30 in December and in
the new issue of Elle she's revealing
the biggest life lessons she's learned
in her 20s ET is breaking down the best
revelations and highlights I don't
understand how you cannot fangirl about
that first up her biggest fear taurine
following the Manchester bombing quote I
was completely terrified to go on tour
this time there was a tremendous amount
of planning expense and effort put into
keeping my fans safe my fear of violence
has continued into my personal life
Taylor says she actually carries army
grade bandages around with her all the
time they're strong enough for gunshots
and stab wounds
she also tackles bullying seemingly
calling out Kim Kardashian and Kanye
West quote a few years ago someone
started an online hate campaign by
calling me a snake on the Internet
she says that left her feeling lower
than she's ever felt in her life and
added I can't tell you how hard I had to
keep from laughing every time my 63 foot
inflatable Cobra named Karen appeared on
stage it would be nice if we could get
an apology from people who bully us but
maybe all I'll ever get is the
satisfaction of knowing I could survive
it and thrive in spite of it is it cool
that I said oh
but when it comes to her real friends
she seems to regret parading around her
squad noting that in high school she was
never a cool kid so quote in my 20s I
found myself surrounded by girls who
wanted to be my friend
so I shouted it from the rooftops posted
pictures and celebrated my newfound
acceptance into a sisterhood without
realizing that other people might still
feel the way I did when I felt so alone
there's sort of like a unspoken code
that we're there for each other and we
would never turn on each other it's like
kind of like this alliance that that is
the best kind of friendship you can have
Taylor also tackles aging and body image
quote I learned to stop hating every
ounce of fat on my body I worked hard to
retrain my brain that a little extra
weight means curves shinier hair and
more energy I work on accepting my body
every day and finally she gets candid
about her parents health struggles
revealing her mom Andrea's cancer is
back quote it's taught me that there are
real problems and then there's
everything else
my mom's cancer is a real problem I used
to be so anxious about daily ups and
downs I give all my worries stress and
prayers to real problems now my mom and
I've always been close we've always been
really good friends I mean she's she's
kept a really good balance between being
very honest with me and and raising me
so that I never ever walked all over but
also being there for me when I really
needed her
[Music]